few activities can summon such strong
emotions as eating and sex food and sex
I think
elicits strong emotions because they
involve crossing the borders of the body
and eating for everyone involves taking
something from outside in and I think
this fact makes eating and makes sex
incredibly threatening because they
permeate those boundaries of the body
that that really in many ways reflect
the boundaries of the self penis meat is
flesh few Chinese can afford a dish some
say was once reserved for Emperor's and
considered forbidden by many in the West
is now served in a high-class Beijing
restaurant called Coralie chuan
the name means strong sexual strength in
the pot some of tonight's key
ingredients have arrived fresh dog and
sheep penis
chef flynn Jing Fu's main customers are
well-heeled businessman and senior
government officials the most expensive
dish on the menu seal penis costs $500
the same amount of Chinese worker earns
in a month chef Lynn thinks it's worth
the price because he believes eating
penis can increase one's libido unit
others do the Chinese have an old saying
that whatever part of an animal you beat
the same part of your body will also be
made stronger so the penis will make you
stronger in sex the restaurants
signature dish is penis hotpot featuring
cow sheep dog donkey and deer penis and
deer testicles the sheep and dog organs
need special preparation the sheep penis
is boiled then skinned in order to
remove any hair
the hair on the dog penis is burnt up
in the West few would eat any part of an
animal they considered a pet but the
restaurants dogs are raised to be eaten
restaurant manager lian-chu sees no link
between them and pets lunch inside yoga
throughout Chinese history dog meat has
been regarded as being verifying
nutrients and Chinese people don't have
a special bond with dogs as there is in
the West Tom and his friend Sam Pearson
arrived for their libido boosting feast
a house specialty rooted in the ancient
traditions of Chinese medicine the
Insurance II ago until Beadle phoom
phoom there's a very date belief that
eating that animal part will heal the
same part of your body this belief is
how most of the Chinese medicine
performed there's no scientific proof of
this belief but the concept is based on
5,000 years of Chinese traditional
medicine and the idea that you are what
you eat
people generally believe that they take
on the properties of what they eat and
that's a general fundamental human
belief it's not it's it's counter to
most of modern science but people still
believe it the hot pot dish is ready
[Music]
customers can order from nine different
animal penises but there are absolutely
no endangered species offered on the
restaurants menu yo nigga young BIA we
have sheep cow yeah dog seal donkey
horse deer and snake penis first the
organs are cooked at the table in a hot
broth before Tom and Sam have their
first taste of animal penis we're gonna
need a stiff drink I think so a cheese
cheese
[Music]
it's the bring door I'm going for the
deer penis and the brown sauce even
cooked with the help of a spicy dipping
sauce the thick membranes encasing the
penis can make it tough and chewy still
don't it's quite chewy